hi my name is reto Meier I'm the tech
lead for Google's Android developer
relations team in this efficient data
transfers dev bite I'm going to
demonstrate a couple of quick techniques
that you can use to better understand
when your application is making network
requests the aim is to modify the data
transfer profile of your apps to
optimize for minimizing the battery
drain caused by activating the salt
radio as you may have already seen in my
dev bite on understanding the salt radio
it's good practice to use the big cookie
approach to data transfers to avoid a
fragmented network traffic profile it
keeps the cell radio powered up
indefinitely in favor of minimizing the
number of radio state transitions and
before you optimize your code you need a
way to generate these graphs that show
exactly when your app is transferring
data and to understand what you're
looking for so you can look for areas
that need improvement there are several
tools you can use for this most simply
you can use logcat to generate log
entries that define the timing
information of your network requests and
at their start and end points and then
use the export of log file to graph the
output using the graphing tool of your
choice if you'd like someone to handle
that graphing step for you AT&T offer
the open-source application resource
optimizer or arrow tool will generate
the pretty graphs and even overlay the
battery state model as well as providing
you with specific recommendations based
on their analysis of your app another
great alternative is to use the network
statistics tab in the DDMS view which is
part of the android developer tools as
you can see in this screenshot it
displays the amount of data being
transferred in the direction of the data
flow additionally you can tag your
output sockets to color code your data
transfers making it easier for you to
see where each transfer is originating
if you're using the HTTP client to
execute your transfers the thread stats
tag associated with the current thread
will automatically be associated with
the socket used for transfers using the
HTTP client note that for soccer taking
to work you need a device running
jellybean or higher so once you've
generated a representation of your apps
transfer profile you can start analyzing
it full battery inefficiencies most
important thing to look for any periodic
transfers any regular pattern of
repeating transfers will cause a chorus
namely regular pattern of radio
activations so you're effectively
setting the minimum level of battery
drain so the shorter the period between
updates the higher the battery drain now
in this example the period is 15 seconds
more than enough to keep the battery
powered up indefinitely but depending on
the device and carrier even a period
over a minute maybe enough to present
prevent the radio from ever dropping
into standby mode completely now we can
incrementally reduce the battery impact
by lowering frequency of these regular
transfers but a better approach is to
try and eliminate periodic updates
completely allowing your apt to have a
baseline of no battery drain now
periodic data transfer spikes it
typically an indicator of either
irregular scheduled upload such as
analytics or ad impressions or client
signed scheduled polling generally
implemented using a timer or repeating
alarm you can eliminate both using some
simple best practices anything that's
not time-sensitive such as analytics
data ad impressions or anything else
that doesn't have a direct impact on the
user experience should be queued up and
batch to be transferred together as a
group the best approach is to simply
fill the queue and trigger all these
delay tolerant downloads the st. the
next time you need to perform something
that is time sensitive like downloading
new music updated headlines current
sports scores whatever data your users
are interacting with if time in
sensitive data is the only data you
transfer you may find it necessary to
schedule a daily think in that scenario
the best approach is to use a sync
adapter to handle this for you we'll
cover that in another div by but we're a
repeating alarm is the only thing that
will work you can try and optimize that
by randomizing the periodicity as shown
here make the frequency as low as
possible if you're palling your server
to check for updates you should do
everything in your power to replace
client-side palling with Google Cloud
messaging this technology lets you send
messages from your server to specific
application instances through Google's
cloud messaging infrastructure so
instead of having each device pull your
server every 15 15 or 60 minutes to
check for updates which may or may not
exist you can have your server notify
each device when there's new information
ready for it to download the results as
an improved user experience thanks to
both better battery efficiency and lower
latency updates I examined both sync
adapters and Google Cloud messaging in
more detail as well as exploring some
other approaches
eliminating repeating transfers later in
this devbyte series for now having
eliminated periodic transfers let's look
at some more indicators for potential
efficiency improvements another pattern
to look for is short spikes either in
height or duration while they may not be
regular they typically indicate
transfers that could be bundled together
in the same way as periodic transfers or
possibly batch together or even pre
fetched the same thing goes for
transfers of any kind that happen in
close proximity but don't quite overlap
now it's significantly more efficient to
have transfers happen when the radio is
already in its active state so when a
time-sensitive transfer is initiated for
whatever reason you should look at look
to preempt any transfers which are
likely to occur within the next few
minutes this is particularly true of any
scheduled transfers but also includes
potentially user-initiated transverse
now for example say you haven't user if
your first perform a download to let the
user read a full article that you
haven't yet prefetched you should use
this as an opportunity to prefetch other
articles that they're likely to read
next particularly if switching between
your articles as simple as swiping left
or right now alternatively if the action
is time-sensitive but not critical for
example uploading an image it might be
worth holding off for up to 30 seconds
just in case another transfer is
initiated in the interim now perhaps not
surprisingly this functionality is built
into the sync adapter which also handles
things like lost connectivity and
battering transfers across applications
so it makes it a great approach for
handling all of your data transfers I'll
dive into that and further efficient
data transfer topics in more detail and
other devbytes in their series including
how to implement some of those best
practices using simple code patterns
Google Cloud messaging and the sync
adapter